député MoDem de alloire merci d'être
avec nous monsieur un faux France Info
ce matin on a appris qu'ils habitborn
allait envoyer une lettre au syndicat la
semaine prochaine pour leur proposer une
rencontre mais attention il y a une
subtilité c'est pas une rencontre de
l'intersonical mais chaque syndicat
séparément bilatéral comme on dit est-ce
que la ficelle est pas un peu grosse on
sent qu'ils avaient bornes elle veut
fracturer l'intersonicale l'unité en
voyant ce qui diront oui ce qui diront
non moi je vois pas ça comme ça d'abord
le président de la République la semaine
dernière vous savez a reçu les syndicats
de patron et puis on a enfin on arrive à
un agenda social il faut parler aux
syndicats il faut après cette période
sur les retraites difficiles parler de
tous les sujets qui sont sur la table et
un en particulier ok c'est celui
notamment le partage de la valeur en
clair comment la feuille augmente de
quoi parle-t-on c'est avec qui
parle-t-on et là on sent bien qu'ils
habitent borne elle dit bah tiens il y a
des syndicats qui vont peut-être dire
oui d'autres qui vont dire non et comme
ça on fracture peut-être un peu ce front
non je pense que chacun se rend station
de responsabilité il verra ce qu'il veut
apporter comme réponse mais d'abord il
est pas inutile qui est justement une
bilatérale puis après
n'empêche pas qu'il peut y avoir une
rencontre avec l'ensemble des syndicats
parce que je crois que la question va
être posée par tous vous savez ils ont
travaillé pendant 8 mois ça ce fameux
barbare Annie Accor national
interprofessionnel comment puis des
salaires plus de dividendes plus
d'action plus de participation moi je
trouve ça plutôt très bien qu'elle
prenne le temps de l'apaisement les voir
de discuter de discuter avec eux de la
feuille de la fameuse route dont on
parle alors elle précise bien les
services de madignan précise à France
Info qui a pas d'obligation et que
surtout que ces rencontres bilatérales
ne constituent pas les négociations
engagées par ailleurs vous l'avez évoqué
pour l'instant avec simplement les
représentants du patronat mais les
syndicats sont également invités pour
préparer la loi travail de fin d'année
absolument mais il y a une première loi
qui doit arriver à l'Assemblée c'est de
partager des valeurs elle est attendue
puis par les vrais réunions entre les
syndicats ils sont tombés d'accord
maintenant c'est aux politiques de
transcrire dans la loi ce cet accord et
d'ailleurs j'aimerais bien que chaque
force politique dise que il va valider
cet accord historique parce que c'est un
accord qui a été longuement défini
longuement et qui va vraiment va
apporter une vraie réponse en tout cas
nous les centrises la majorité nous
soutiendrons cet accord et puis il y a
pas que cela il y a la transposition
d'un accord sur les actions du travail
la maladie professionnelle qui doit
rentrer en ligne de compte et puis
ensuite et ça veut dire il y a pas de
problème avec les syndicats ils ont déjà
fait leur travail et voilà là ça veut
dire que social existe dans ce pays
qu'il faut maintenant continuer et il
appartient la première vidéo de le
relancer alors à Matignon précise aussi
que il est pas question d'une conférence
générale où on mettrait tous les sujets
à plat est-ce que vous au modem vous
souhaitez quand même que soit organisé
ce type de réunion avec cette emballage
moi j'estime qu'il faut deux choses oui
il faut des rencontres bilatérales mais
aussi il faut donner une perspective une
stratégie des modalités parce que sinon
personne ne sera vraiment ouvert donc
les syndicats font leur dire écoutez on
va se remettre autour d'une table et on
va regarder les sujets qui sont les
vôtres et comment on a perdu solution un
exemple l'essuie de la pénibilité pour
partir à zéro comment va-t-on faire le
sujet des métiers les plus tendus sur
lesquels on a des difficultés majeures
de recrutement comment fait-on la
réforme de la formation professionnelle
comment et tous ces sujets là
pardonnez-moi c'est le sujet des
partenaires sociaux donc il faut en
discuter avec eux globalement et puis un
par un journée de mobilisation
aujourd'hui de la CGT c'est les préludes
évidemment à la journée du 1er mai
comment vous voyez vous cette
manifestation du premier les syndicats
c'est une façon de fermer la parenthèse
de la comptation de la réforme ou c'est
une façon de la poursuivre pour eux
d'abord c'est un moment historique tous
les syndicats sont unis c'est pas
toujours été le cas deuxièmement c'est
qu'ils ont été privés de 1er mai avec la
covid donc il y aura beaucoup de monde
Mélenchon il est pas syndicaliste mais
lui s'occupe beaucoup de la vie
syndicale donne déjà des rendez-vous au
14 juillet ils continueront
manifestement de montrer leurs désaccord
c'est un stand des questions mais ce que
je veux dire simplement section Comment
ça réussir cette conférence sociale que
nous les Centris nous appelons de nos
vœux d'ailleurs c'est pas d'aujourd'hui
je vous le dis on me le disais on peut
le mettre en prise dans le groupe il y a
plus de deux mois c'est vrai et bien et
nous avions dit également aussi sur les
retraites il fallait ce bilan vu
parcours bref ce dialogue social il doit
être de façon permanente dans le pays on
ne peut pas être dans un pays dans
lesquels il y a les décides en un côté
et les syndicats de l'autre ça ne marche
pas alors il y a des mouvements en ce
moment en Seine-Saint-Denis la part CGT
pas loin du stade de France
demain soir il y aura la finale de la
Coupe de France traditionnellement le
président de la République descend sur
la pelouse pour se faire présenter les
joueurs est-ce que ça serait plus
prudent pour Emmanuel Macron qu'il n'y
aille pas d'abord un c'est une grande
fête populaire une fête du foot la Coupe
de France c'est un moment absolument
symbolique et le football américain
vous pouvez y aller ce qu'ils veulent
c'est normal je souhaite simplement que
la police protège cette manifestation
qui est pas le débordement et puis
ensuite j'espère qu'il préserveront ce
grand moment sportif pas comme le match
d'argent hier soir pendant trois quart
d'heure il y a pas une lumière ça serait
vraiment bien bien parce que gâcher la
fête tu l'as faite qu'est-ce que vous
avez pensé de la visite d'Emmanuel
Macron hier surprise en tout cas
inscrite à son agenda
il va au contact on lui reprochait
d'être dans son château de ne pas sortir
de ne pas aller voir les français il va
au contact en plus il a fait des visites
impromptuelles j'ai l'encourage à
continuer c'est dur et pas inscrite
c'est dur mais c'est comme ça vous savez
il y a une très belle phrase du Gérard
Larcher puis dans du Sénat il faut
apporter une engueulade c'est aussi
apporter d'explications moi je
m'aperçois à l'autre jour la première
ministrement à 6 reprises elle a été
interrogée sur le retraites 5 fois sur 6
des mauvaises informations avaient été
mises dans la tête des celles et ceux
qui posent des questions bien sûr c'est
pas toujours populaire mais vous savez
je le dis depuis le début pas un seul
gouvernement reviendra en arrière sur
cette forme de retraite parce que quand
vous rencontrez un jeune dans la rue qui
a 30 ans il parle pas de la retraite il
dit de toute façon j'aurais pas de
retraite moi j'ai envie de lui dire je
te parle de taille de taille sur les
casseroles vous faut que ça s'arrête
parti un peu du folklore bon c'est mieux
d'avoir un dialogue de plus apaisé mais
bon on sait que ça se passe comme ça je
suis persuadé que les choses
s'atténueront rappelez-vous les gilets
jaunes au début lorsqu'il allait faire
des rencontres trois quatre cinq six
heures tout le monde c'est un truc de
fou ça sortira pas au bout d'un moment
la couleur retombera parce que les
Français nous trouveront un sens dans
cette démarche même si il reste en
colère et j'entends cette colère cette
colère il faut l'apaiser et l'apaiser
par dialogue social alors on va évoquer
maintenant les déserts médicaux parce
que vous êtes membre d'un groupe
transpartisan donc avec tous les parties
fins presque tous les groupes politiques
croient qu'il y a pas des gens du RN
mais il y a des insoumis ou il y a les
assouler et les insoumis ce que je vous
dis pas le RM les insoumis ou vous
réfléchissez ensemble comment lutter
contre les déserts médicaux vous
organisez des Tours de France
vous voulez obliger les médecins à
s'installer là où il y a des déserts
médicaux c'est ça l'idée
sur la démarche
transpartisol vous savez on parle
souvent transpartisan est-ce qu'on est
capable de faire des majorités des
crédithes voyez vous avez la
démonstration qu'entre ce genre de bonne
intelligence quand vous sortiez de
l'hémicie qu'il y a les effets de manche
de tribune on est capable de se
retrouver sur des sujets majeurs comme
celui de l'accès aux soins première
priorité absolue des Français
il faut simplement dans les zones là où
il y a un excédent entre guillemets de
professionnels de santé là c'est le
remplacement black à plaque qui
m'explique si vous partez à la retraite
un médecin peut vous remplacer donc
c'est une régulation minimum mais c'est
mettre un petit pied dans la porte mais
surtout c'est faire en sorte qu'il a
permanence des soins permette à chaque
Français à chaque français d'avoir un
médecin traitant ce qui n'est pas le cas
pour 5 millions d'entre eux et je suis
persuadé que l'esprit de responsabilité
des personnels soignants marchera parce
que pour moi aide-soignant dans le
public ou dans le privé si avoir une
responsabilité mais a priori c'est pas
vos propositions qui a retenu Emmanuel
Macron pour faire un projet de loi ou
pas terminé il y a une autre proposition
de la majorité qui sort on en reparlera
et vous verrez qu'on se rapprochera
merci beaucoup bonne journée à vous
monsieur